siamo qui per
harvey come è nata e che cos'è
quando avete sentito questo tema
a che cosa avete pensato a qualcosa di
prezioso forse a delle risorse nascoste
è un po questo il tema chiave dei
giacimenti urbani quando mi sono trovata
a fondare questa associazione che mira a
ridurre gli sprechi a favorire
l'economia circolare lavorando dal basso
partendo dai cittadini e mettendo i
comunicazioni tutti i vari soggetti
mi sono ricordata di un'intervista che
avevo fatto nel 2006 per un femminile di
fascia medio alta di moda ero riuscita a
convincere il direttore a fare un pezzo
sul valore del rifiuto non era stato
facilissimo perché i tempi non erano
assolutamente maturi però non so si vede
che erano stata convincente e mi aveva
concesso parecchie pagine da scrivere
perché erano poi quattro pagine
pubblicate che non è poco
quindi per dare contenuto alla alla mia
intervista al mio lavoro aveva ero
partita dal direttore generale del conai
il consorzio nazionale per il recupero
degli imballaggi
allora la raccolta differenziata era
agli inizi nel senso che esisteva da
neanche dieci anni ed era un po il conai
era il punto di riferimento chiave per
chi voleva occuparsi di riciclo rifiuti
e di valore del rifiuto mentre aspettavo
che il direttore generale che era allora
giancarlo longo venisse al telefono
riflettevo tra me e me è
preoccupatissima perché ho detto ma
questo cosa mi potrà mai dire che io
posso raccontare le mie lettrici ero
seriamente preoccupate ho paura di aver
fatto un buco nell'acqua
dopo di che questo signore viene al
telefono e dopo poche frasi mi convince
che avevo centrato l'obiettivo nel senso
che mi dice signora i rifiuti
metropolitani sono i nostri nuovi
giacimenti urbani l'italia è un paese
molto povero di materia prima
i rifiuti sono la nostra materia prima
seconda il futuro della nostra economia
è lì quindi tenga presente che ad
esempio una tonnellata di bottiglie di
plastica vale 400 euro a tonnellata
questo allora poi prezzi oscillano
dipende dal
peccato però mi ha fatto che abbia
aperto un mondo ho capito che c'era un
senso a tutto questo e quindi quando poi
mi sono trovata a voler fondare questa
associazione
mi è ritornato in mente questa
intervista e mi sono appropriata delle
parole di giancarlo longo e chi perché è
nata questa associazione perché io avevo
in mente come giornalista ambientale
avevo in mente i dati relativi alla
produzione enorme di rifiuti italiana e
non solo i dati della dei costi di
gestione della stessa
e poi avevo in mente la devastazione che
era in corso sul nostro pianeta
nel senso che questa è l'opera di uno
street artist che si chiamano el douglas
che appunto rappresentato la terra come
una sorta di mela smangiucchiata piena
di rifiuti non è la fantasia di un
artista purtroppo noi sappiamo che
esiste la green shots dei short shoot
the youth day che corrisponde al giorno
in cui noi ogni anno andiamo a terminare
le risorse che la terra ci ha offerto
per quell'anno ogni anno questa data si
anticipa l'anno scorso è stato lotto di
agosto quest'anno sarà il 2 di agosto
per cui noi tendiamo consumare molto di
più di quello che abbiamo a disposizione
di contro c'è un'altra ecco questo
sempre per rimanere al discorso
dell'esaurimento delle risorse questa è
una ricerca fatta dalla università di
york sui tempi di esaurimento degli ai
vari elementi chimici quelli che sono in
rosso non si vedono tanto bene sono
quelli che andranno ad esaurimento al 35
50 anni tra questi c'è lo zinco e cielo
e magnesio e dopo di che questi sono i
tassi di riciclo ci sono dei materiali
magnesio che colmano il manganese
scusate il mio man manganese che vengono
riciclati altri come lo zinco per il
proprio per cui non se ne parla proprio
ha comunque c'è una reale emergenza da
questo punto di vista e noi la dobbiamo
tenere presente scusate ritorno all'ora
voi sapete quanto produciamo di rifiuti
all'anno in italia in media una cifra
mostruosa circa 30 milioni di tonnellate
il cittadino medio italiano nel 2015
questi sono i dati del rapporto ispra
del 2016 ha prodotto 400 88 kg di
rifiuti all'anno
poi ci sono regioni più virtuose che
nessuno penserebbe ma di fatto ad
esempio la calabria ne produce 407 kg
regioni come l'emilia romagna ne
producono 600 42 chili all'anno anche se
poi magari noi ce la immaginiamo con una
ragione virtuosi si apre poi riciclano
un po di più però sono un disastro
voi siete piuttosto bravi perché novara
so che ne producono prodotti 465 kg per
cittadino adesso può essere che sia
anche un po scesa nel senso che tra
crisi e sensibilizzazione i dati un po
scendono però rimane un dato inquietante
che per per gestire tutti questi rifiuti
noi spendiamo 380 euro a tonnellata 380
euro per 30 milioni fanno più di 11
miliardi di euro l'anno una mostruosa di
tutti questi rifiuti noi andiamo a
compostare il 16 per cento
riciclare il 28 per cento ma poi
buttiamo in discarica il 28 per cento il
27 per cento lo inceneriamo quindi noi
abbiamo più del 50 per cento dei rifiuti
che produciamo che ho comportano danni
enormi come nella discarica che nella
visione dell'unione europea andrà
abolita entro il 2030 nel senso che
dovrà essere non più del 5 per cento
oppure nell'incenerimento noi comunque
andiamo a svalutare un bene che potremo
riutilizzare ecco dopo le cattive
notizie ci sono anche le buone notizie
nel senso che se se c'è qualcosa che non
torna nel senso che noi devastiamo la
terra produciamo una marea di rifiuti li
paghiamo perdiamo la gestione e adesso
dobbiamo riuscire invece a ridurre
questa cosa dobbiamo assolutamente
ridurre i nostri non i consumi ridurre
i propri rifiuti quindi giacimenti
urbani che cosa fa giacimenti urbani a
mira a mappare le attività del
territorio che favoriscono la riduzione
degli sprechi perché lavorano sulla
prevenzione ovvero ad esempio progettano
prodotti che siano riciclabili al 100
per cento o compostabili oppure soggetti
che facciano refeel per cui risultati
utilizzo nello stesso contenitore per
l'olio per l'acqua per il vino eccetera
cito un esempio scusate quando sono
arrivata qui ma mi capita in quasi tutti
i luoghi in cui vado quando chiedo
dell'acqua non mi viene data una
bottiglia di vetro con dell'acqua
mi viene data una bottiglia di plastica
con un bicchiere usa e getta
tendenzialmente di plastica è accaduto
anche qui ma non perché siano più
cattivi di altri ma perché lo fanno
tutti cioè la norma anche perché i primi
diffidenti siamo noi noi cittadini nel
senso che a volte non ci fidiamo
dell'acqua che troviamo nei comuni dove
l'acqua è buona non tutti purtroppo sono
così è un primo spreco da da evitare
comunque ritornando a noi quindi noi
lavoriamo su chi fa prevenzione
chi fa riparazione perché dobbiamo
prolungare la vita degli oggetti
soprattutto gli oggetti di qualità
verranno manutenuti vanno tenuti il più
possibile perché abbiamo a monte abbiamo
fatto abbiamo estratto materia prima
consumato energia consumato acqua quel
punto godiamoceli più possibile
ripariamo lì poi cerchiamo di
evidenziare i soggetti kg riusano anche
semplicemente perché riusa nello stesso
libro come al libraccio con i libri
usati o perché fanno riuso creativo
oppure perché li trasformano in
qualcos'altro c'è una meravigliosa
azienda che recupera le reti da pesca e
li trasforma in una nuova fibra che
diventa fibra per delle moquette di
grandissimo pregio per cui c'è una
valorizzazione di quel rifiuto e dopo di
che noi cerchiamo di le chiaramente ci
mettiamo anche chi li utilizza e chi
ricicla allora che cosa cerchiamo di
fare noi cerchiamo di mettere in tanto
di mettere a disposizione dei cittadini
una mappa della
le possono servirsi per gestire al
meglio i loro materiali e i loro oggetti
ma anche una mappa per far parlare i
diversi soggetti tra di loro i cittadini
con chi ha delle attività e le attività
tra di loro mi è successo di recente vi
scrivono per le cose più strane ma hanno
scritto di recente per chiedermi era una
laboratorio di depurazione delle acque
che ogni anno butta via circa 100
tonnellate di resine che vengono
utilizzate per la depurazione mi ha
detto se da noi le bruciava ogni anno
cosa ne possiamo fare
io non sono una chimica o una formazione
umana domani sta però e sto cercando di
rivolgermi ai soggetti che conosco per
vedere se questo materiale invece di
essere bruciato non può essere
riutilizzato e ci sono miliardi di
occasioni per riutilizzare i materiali e
gli oggetti e avere nuove risorse sono
beni questi sono beni che noi non abbia
conserviamo in casa nostra o che avranno
un futuro perché daranno lavoro a delle
persone
allora noi appunto mettiamo e dopo di
che partendo dai principi
l'unione europea ha una gerarchia sua
precisa la gerarchia dell'unione europea
prevede prima la prevenzione poi riuso
come terzo step il riciclo e quarto
insomma ma il consideratelo cioè è la
valorizzazione energetica quindi se noi
quando noi abbiamo davanti un oggetto
noi dobbiamo fare dei ragionamenti per
vedere qual è il migliore utilizzo di
quell'oggetto dove cosa ne dobbiamo fare
vi faccio una domanda riprova a farmi
delle domande è vedere un pochino
se troviamo una lunghezza d'onda ad
esempio dovete organizzare una festa di
20 persone quali stoviglie usate
ditemelo confessare non assenti brava
ecco questa è la soluzione migliore
perché invece eletto stoviglie di
plastica sono un costo comportano
inquinamento quando le si produce
portano inquinamento quando la si
dismette cioè nel senso che se proprio
non possiamo usare le proprie storie le
nostre stoviglie che poi sono anche più
eleganti più belle più che anche se no
si ma sono più divertenti magari con i
tovaglioli di stoffa che basta st carta
che è la cosa sarebbe il massimo dopo di
che se proprio non ce la facciamo usiamo
il cartone usiamo i materiali
biodegradabili ma la plastica teniamola
come ultima soluzione e se proprio la
dobbiamo usare usiamo una plastica
duratura che ci serva del tempo vi
faccio un altro esempio ferro da stiro
ferro da stiro di qualità che si rompe
cosa facciamo del ferro da stiro di
qualità che si rompe e brava e si prova
ma se zero cioè a me succede io ne ho
una stirella che ha 20 anni e lei ogni
due tre anni vuole che io la porti dal
manutentore perché se no non c'è verso e
io resisto poi è chiaro che ti dicono ma
se tu continui con questa riparazione
spendi quanto furono di fatto però il
ferro nuovo 90 su 100 si rompe prima il
ferro nuovo non è stato cioè premente
arriva ad altri paesi non ha dato lavoro
a soggetti che vivono in italia e
sappiamo benissimo qual è il giro che
varia si va a fare e noi che cosa
facciamo noi facciamo lavoriamo sulla
sensibilizzazione come in questa
occasione facendo anche a mostre
facciamo delle mostre assieme ai nostri
associati in cui loro mostrano quello
che fanno
non so partecipiamo a fa la cosa giusta
in cascina cuccagna citata prima da
campagnoli organizziamo un evento
omonimo giacimenti urbania novembre per
la settimana europea della riduzione
chiudi per cui ci sono diversi soggetti
che fanno cose di qualità legate a
queste tematiche per cui cioè non lo so
riusano ma in un modo non solo le
vecchie vele tra diventa borse diventano
cuscini ci sono c'è addirittura un socio
che lavora nella protezione ambiente
marino che ha studiato un sistema per
utilizzare la pelle di scarto del pesce
un altro che lavora invece sui
biomateriali alternativi alla plastica
ed a fa la cosa giusta mi hanno fatto
una mossa che sia chiamato l'eterno
ritorno e natura non esistono scarti ma
solo risorse su tutta una serie di
materiali alternativi alla plastica che
hanno il vantaggio di essere
biodegradabili c'era il pannolino c'era
il bio fomc e alternativo al polistirolo
che usiamo nelle vaschette del gelato
piuttosto che nelle vasche del pe nelle
cassette del pesce perché volte presente
sulle spiagge noi troviamo tutto il
polistirolo rotto eccetera quali sono le
casse del pesce che cascano in mare si
rompono i pesci se li mangiano
sappiamo che tutti che è esatto noi
mangiamo polistirolo ci sia più plastica
che pesci e noi dobbiamo fare qualcosa
cioè dobbiamo diventare dei minatori
se non parte da noi l'accordo che
abbiamo una potenza pazzesca perché
l'abbiamo potenza del consumatore
se il consumatore inizia ad avere
un'altra direzione devono avere una
direzione un'altra direzione anche le
aziende anche le grosse aziende oltre a
quelle piccole poi noi facciamo network
tra di noi nel senso che tra di noi con
tra i tre soggetti che partecipano alla
nostra rete cerchiamo di scambiare
materiali oggetti idee proposte
devo di smettere che ne so la credenza e
si trova una soluzione o il materiale
tal di tali da dismettere vi interessa e
via dicendo
facciamo poi due eventi ricorrenti che
che ritornano nel tempo che sono lo
spazio tutto gratis ovvero ogni 2 3 mesi
organizziamo in per un weekend uno
spazio dove ci ospitano di norma dove è
possibile tutto quello e portare tutto
quello che a noi non serve più me ancora
in buone condizioni e prendere quello
che ci pare fino a cinque pezzi
le due cose non sono collegate proprio
il principio del dono a me non serve io
te lo do
e poi sia te serve lo prendi questa
invece restar parti lo facciamo in
collaborazione con il re starters a
milano c'è pc officina sono dei soggetti
che si nostri associati che si ritrovano
tutti i martedì e offrono consulenza
gratuita per riparare le persone che
vanno e poi di tanto in tanto una volta
al mese fanno del resto a parte in giro
per la città per cui ho a casa
non so voi però ha per nome è un
disastro si accumulano quantità di cose
rotte
io non butto perché faccio scrupolo
evidentemente dopo tutto questo discorso
però devo trovare il modo per gestirle
andranno restar parti si verifica quali
sono le possibilità di possibilità hanno
di essere riparate ecco vengo questo è
quello che noi facciamo e cerchiamo di
sé quando troviamo delle nuove occasioni
per ragionare sulle cose sui processi ci
attiviamo quello chiudo con due cose il
principio base di giacimenti urbani è
che in natura non esistono scarti ma
sono risorse non solo rispetto ai
materiali ma anche rispetto alle persone
siamo tutti delle risorse la terra una
risorsa però bisogna trattarci bene come
umani e anche anche rispetto alla natura
bisogna avere un atteggiamento
rispettoso questa cosa a questo a questo
discorso
vorrei dare un tono nobile citando la
cultura prevedi calindri antica nelle di
antica c'era un dio che era rudra poi
diventato usciva che presiedeva al
corretto svolgimento dei sacrifici ma la
funzione principale di rudra era sì
vedere che il sacrificio avesse un
procedimento corretto ma era soprattutto
verificare che venisse rispettato
l'avanzo e lui era il dio dell'avanzo e
dello scarto perché senza lo scarto non
era possibile sacrificio successivo
riflettete noi siamo sulla terra una
specie di astronave noi non possiamo
pensare di avere dei rifiuti che
buttiamo via in continuazione perché non
abbiamo più la terra e siamo solo unico
rifiuto come la foto della inizio quindi
invito a tutti all'azione contattateci
se ci fa piacere
attiviamo anche a novara giacimenti
urbani
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]